[Music]
oh
HB that's too strong cuz it is my
favorite holiday but all this year's
been a busy BL don't think I have the
energy to add my already mad rush just
cuz it's is the season the perfect gift
for me would be completions and
connections left from last year ski shop
en counter most interesting at his
number but never the time most of 81
pass on those l so deck those Halls trim
those trees raise up cups of Christmas
Che I just need to catch my breath
Christmas by myself this
[Music]
year H the picture Frozen landscape CH
this room for 24 days Evergreen
sparkling Stone get this winner over
with flashback to Spring Time s again
would have been good to go for lunch
couldn't agree and we were both free we
tried we said we' keep in touch didn't
of course till summertime out to the
beach to his boat could I join him no
this time it was me sunburn in the third
degree now the Calendar's just one page
of course I am excited tonight a night
I've set my mind not to do too much
about
it
[Music]
[Applause]
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas but I
think one year Merry chm Merry
[Music]
Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas chrm
chras dasing through the sow cuz I
bundled up too tight last minute have to
do a few cards a few calls because it's
RSVP no thanks no party lights it's
Christmas Eve going to relax turn down
all of my advice last fall ahead and
night my myself same guy called
Halloween party waited all night for him
to show this time his car wouldn't go
forget it's cold it's getting late TR on
home is celebrate in a quiet way on wine
doing Christmas right this
[Music]
[Applause]
time and he has provided me with the
world's smallest Turkey already in the
oven nice and hot oh damn guess what I
forgot so on with the boots back out in
the snow to the only all night grocery
when what's my wondering eyes should
appear in the line is that guy I've been
chasing all year then in this one alone
he said me to break this year's been
crazy I said me to but why are you you
mean you forgot cranberries too then
suddenly we laughed and laugh caught on
to what was happening that Christmas
magic brought this tail to a very happy
ending
Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas meras Merry
christmasm Merry chras Merry
[Music]
christmasm Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
[Music]
hey friends there are so many stories
behind this video uh for one I tried
shooting in front of the White House
Christmas tree last year and that really
fancy t uh telephoto lens that I'm using
is the same lens that I used last year
and I made the mistake of setting it on
autofocus rather than manual focus and
halfway through the performance um I
went out of focus and the tree itself
became sharply INF focus and I really
wanted to give you all that nice uh
background bouquet um and doing it this
year uh since Christmas is not a big
thing for me I I really wanted to dig
around and found that uh that that uh
lost hit from the80s uh Christmas
rapping by The Waitresses is one of the
one of the few Christmas songs that I
really really dig so I thought I would
share that all with you I hope I I wish
you all happy holidays whatever your hap
your uh your holidays happen to be uh
real quickly though uh I just want to
give a huge thank you to flow toys for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to go out and try again with that
really awesome lens if you'd like to uh
grab a set of those um uh those flow
mojoy that I'm using in this video uh
you can do so by using the code
drexfactor 12 2023 at checkout over at
flowtoys.com that will get you a 10%
discount on your order of any prop in
their online store and even better it
helps out the channel so thank you so
much flow toys for uh sponsoring this
video and giving me an excuse to go out
and play with really nice
lenses um speaking of thank yous I
should also drop a thank you to the
Friends of the channel so big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrot light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies by checking out the
links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel That is Becca beckin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my Mission uh this
video would not be possible without my
awesome supporters on patreon in
particular I would love to shout out my
flow patrons who are listed on screen
right now um if you dig seeing the
videos that I post on YouTube the best
way for you to support them is to go
sign up as a regular patreon supporter
there's a lot of things that I do to
bring in income through the front door
um but a lot of them actually take me
away from making videos so if are the
thing that you like and the thing you
want to see more of patreon is the best
way to do it uh you can do that by going
and signing up over at
patreon.com direct Factor po so go check
that out pretty pleaseed and thank you
uh and if you'd like to check out some
of the other uh performance and flow
videos I've done over the years I will
go ahead and leave a link to uh a
playlist of those videos down in the
description thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourself this weekend and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace